but on Mars with only 38% of Earth's
gravity water behaves differently the
irrigation systems must be carefully
designed to deliver water directly to
the roots without flooding the soil or
allowing water to evaporate too quickly
in Mars's low gravity water doesn't flow
the same way to overcome this SpaceX has
developed a system that delivers
precisely controlled amounts of water
directly to the pl
Roots this drip irrigation system
ensures that the crops receive exactly
the amount of water they need no more no
less the water is then recycled filtered
and reused creating a closed loop system
that maximizes efficiency